Is that the source of, uh,
if you were able to deconstruct like where some of your best ideas came from
do, is there a process that's at the core of that? Like, so some people,
you know, walk and think some people like in the shower,
the best ideas hit them. If you talk about like Newton,
Apple hitting him on the head.
No, I, I, I found out a long time ago. Um, I processed things so much slowly.
So like in college I had friends who could study at the last minute, get an,
a next day. I can't do that at all. So I always front load at all the work.
Like I do all the problems early, you know, for finals,
like the last three days, I wouldn't look at a book because I want, you know,
cause like a new fact day before finals may screw up my understanding of what I
thought I knew. So it, my, my, my goal was to always get it in and,
and give it time to soak. And I used to, you know,
I remember when we were doing like 3d calculus,
I would have these amazing dreams of 3d surfaces for normal, you know,
cleaning the gradient. And it just was like all come up. So it was really fun,
like very visual. And, uh, and if I got cycles of that, that was useful.
Um, and the other is, is don't over filter your ideas. Like,
I like that process of brainstorming where lots of ideas can happen.
I like people who have lots of ideas, but then there's a, yeah,
I'll let them sit and let it breathe a little bit and then reduce it to
practice. Like at some point you really have to,
does it really work? Like, is this real or not? Right.
But you, but you have to do both there's creative tension there.
Like how do you be both open and precise?
Have you had ideas that you just that's in your mind for like years before the
sure. Isn't interesting. A way to
generate ideas and just let them sit, let them sit there for awhile.
I think I have a few of those ideas.
Yeah. That was so funny. Yeah. I think that's, you know, creativity,
uh, this one or something.
For the slow thinkers in the, in the room, I suppose. Cause I, some people,
like you said are just like, like the.
Yeah, it's really interesting. There's so much diversity in how people think,
you know, how fast or slow they are, how well they remember don't, you know,
I'm not super good at remembering facts, but processes and methods,
like an orange theory.
I went to Penn state and almost all our engineering tests were open book.
I could remember the page and not the formula, but as soon as I saw the formula,
I could remember the whole method if I, if I learned it, you know?
So it was just a funny where some people could, you know,
I just watched friends like flipping through the book,
trying to find the formula, even knowing that they'd done just as much work.
And I would just open the book and I was on page 27, bottom half.
I could see the whole thing visually. Yeah. You know.
And you have to learn that about yourself and figure out what the function
optimally. Yeah.
I had a friend who, who was always concerned.
He didn't know how he came up with ideas. He had lots of ideas, but he said,
they just sort of popped up. Like, he'd be working on something,
you had this idea. And it was like, where does it come from?
But you can have more awareness of it. Like, like, like how you,
how your brain works is a little murky as you go down from the voice in your
head or the obvious visualizations. Like when you visualize something,
how does that happen? You know, if I say, you know, visualize volcano,
it's easy to do it. Right.
What does it actually look like when you visualize it?
I can visualize to the point where I don't see the very much out of my eyes and
I see the colors of the thing I'm visualizing.
Yeah. But there's like a sh there's a shape. There's a texture, there's a color,
but there's also conceptual visualization.
Like what are you actually visualizing when you visualize it in volcano?
Just like with peripheral vision, you think you see the whole thing.
That's a good way to say it. You know, you have this kind of,
almost peripheral vision of your visualizations are like these ghosts.
But you know, if you, if you work on it,
you can get a pretty high level of detail.
And somehow you can walk along those visualizations that come up from the
Nigeria, which is a.
But when you're thinking about solving problems, like you're,
you're putting information and you're exercising the stuff you do know you're
sort of teasing the area that you don't understand and don't know,
but you can almost, you know, feel, you know,
that process happening. You know, that's, that's how I like,
like, like I know sometimes when I'm working really hard on something like,
like I get really hot when I'm sleeping and you know, it's like,
we got the blanket throw a couple of all the blankets are on the floor and,
you know, while we wake up and think, wow, that was great, you know?
Well, to, uh, to reverse engineer, what the hell happened there?
Oh, sometimes it's vivid dreams. And sometimes it's just kind of, like you say,
like shadow thinking that you sort of have this feeling or you're going through
this stuff, but it's, it's not that obvious.
Isn't that so amazing that the mind just does all these little experiments.
I never, you know, I thought, I always thought, um,
it's like a river that you can't, you're just there for the ride,
but you're right. If you prep it.
No, it's, it's, it's all understandable. Meditation really helps you.
You got to start figuring out, you need to learn language of your own mind
and there's multiple levels of it, but abstractions again, right.
It's somewhat comprehensible and observable and feelable or whatever
the right word is. Yeah. You're not along for the ride.
You are the ride.